hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 20 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet they set up a whole bunch of big
plot points that I think are gonna pay
off later one of the most fun things
about when they initially cast John
Wesley Shipp for the series first season
one everyone's like oh my god wouldn't
it be awesome if he used to be the flash
somewhere what if he was the Jay Garrick
version of the flash we got season one
that didn't happen but then during
season two when we found out that zoom
really wasn't Jay Garrick he was just
hunter zolomon pretending to be Jay
Garrick everyone was like what if the
real Jay Garrick is the one underneath
the mask that's my sincere hope right
now and then when Henry Allen in the
episode says boom Garrick that's my
mother's maiden name like hmm that's
interesting
it's almost like you can see all the
riders just winking from behind the
camera like did you see did you see the
thing we just did so number 10 WTF
I think that John Wesley Shipp is gonna
be a version of Jay Garrick but I don't
think it's gonna be our version of Henry
on I think it'll be earth to Henry Allen
there's a lot of you that are wondering
now if this means that they're gonna
kill earth one Henry Allen like oh man
does this mean that he's gonna sacrifice
himself but then they'll give us Jay
Garrick Henry Allen from Earth - maybe
but Henry Allen is back in Central City
for the rest of the season
they said for good but that just means
for the rest of the season all bets are
off because they could probably still
kill someone in the finale but number 9
WTF they have a fake flash that they've
been using for the last week this is so
funny Barry just miming it's a good
thing I played so many video games and
he even calls rupture World of Warcraft
Dante number 8 WTF meet rupture earth to
Dante brother of Earth - Cisco who does
a really good job of bringing Cisco
together with his earth one brother
they've been on the outs but number
seven WTF when they watch zoom
assassinate rupture they're both just
like hey yeah I know we hate each other
and all but seriously bro if you didn't
see my trailer video for this episode
that I did a couple days ago I kind of
explained who rupture is he is this
really complicated backstory in the
comics his name is Armando he's another
brother cisco has two brothers in the
comics one of them is Dante the others
Armando that the TV show just
simplifying a lot of that don't worry
about reading rupture stuff but he does
appear in the vibe comic book which was
actually written by Andrew Kreisberg the
flash showrunner so if you really do
like reading comics you can go read
but rupture has this really convoluted
backstory so it's a bit confusing
number six WTF zoom explains his grand
plan to Katelyn oh I'm just gonna kill
everybody except for you and I and I
also want you to turn evil so if you
could do that right now and really help
she just gives him the look like I don't
even understand why you think that would
be a thing so he's not telling her to
turn into a metahuman or anything like
that
he just wants her to fall in line so
that he won't have to be alone anymore
so zoom is like the personification of
sad Affleck given speedforce number five
WTF iris opens up about all the fields
if you are a really big fan of shipping
on the show and you want to see them
together because they're a big comic
book couple then you're totally gonna
dig where they're taking this but don't
expect them to follow the same path is
like some of the more notable
relationships on arrow remains to be
seen if they'll actually consummate
their relationship that was the big
thing happening was that she was
explained to him her true feelings so
that's the first step
consummating that relationship is like a
whole other thing down the line that's
like a whole other barrier for them to
break through they actually just had an
episode of agents of shield that
directly addressed that metaphor
breaking the barrier crossing the
singularity having all the sex number 4
WTF big reveal Cisco is a Harry Potter
fanatic totally not surprised I would
expect that he'd be more into like Star
Wars more science fiction based things
but I think the reason that there were
so many Harry Potter references written
into this is just because the average
age of the person that watches the flash
would have been someone who saw every
single Harry Potter film so of all the
Lightning references like I was thinking
mostly of Metallica jokes but of all the
people all around the world that would
watch this the most common thing that
they would have seen that this wand
would seem like is harry potter so cisco
has now been outed as a harry potter
fanatic how did you know about the
convention number 3 WTF wally and Jesse
find a way out of the Time Vault
in our hit with the blast wave of dark
matter so we'll have to talk about this
more in future videos depending on where
they take it
but this doesn't automatically mean that
this is them getting speedforce because
they're a couple critical components in
reinforce that were not present when
wally and Jesse were hit with the wave
the dark matter so they were just hit
with the wave zoom was hit with the wave
while he was getting shocked with
lightning
was doing the same and he had been
pumped full of all kinds of chemicals
that was why he was starting to go into
shock before the lightening ever struck
like you see him just like going crazy
that's him getting jacked up with all
those chemicals then as the Lightning
starts striking him the blast wave hits
him and all those things in combination
are what give him his speed force powers
but number one WTF he goes dr. Manhattan
if you guys haven't seen Watchmen in a
while just watch the dr. Manhattan scene
where he just turns into pure energy and
has to Rico LS he has to find a way to
reform his body now that's not exactly
what happened with the flesh what I
think is going on here this big
flashpoint moment is that Barry has just
been turned into pure energy and he now
exists inside the Speed Force
that's what next week's episode is
that's Kevin Smith's episode it's called
the runaway dinosaur so I'll let you to
wonder what that might mean that I'll
totally do a trailer video later this
week so lots of exciting stuff set up in
this episode I think they'll pay a lot
of it off before the finale but some of
it might not be fully addressed till
season 3 like that Wally Jesse moment
them getting infused with the dark
matter I think they're gonna explore
that more in season 3 and I'm so excited
I was hoping that Jesse quick would come
back next season because even when they
bring new characters on it's really hard
to tell whether or not the show's gonna
bring him back in a future season or if
it's gonna up them to series regular or
anything like that but we'll just see
how this plays out over the next couple
of episodes I'm not expecting them to
directly address that they'll probably
just be like oh my god we're alive
that's wonderful and then later it'll be
like hey wait something weird is
happening and we'll find out what kind
of powers that are getting here's
something really interesting the Andrew
Kreisberg said about them having other
versions of the flash on the show at one
time like multiple flashes at one time
he said that the TV show isn't called
flash and Friends it's just called the
flash so what I think that means is that
Barry Allen is gonna be the only flash
on the TV show and if they do give Wally
and Jesse powers
they'll be slightly different but they
will get powers because I think that was
what that whole dark matter scene was
about so I think just because they
didn't replicate the exact conditions
that Barry was replicating they're not
gonna get speed force but they will be
metahumans of some type it's like the
show is telling you we want them to be
on Team flash and to be able to
contribute so we're gonna give them some
special powers
Jesse quick is probably the smartest
person in the building
Wally's a good engineer so like they'll
have other ways beyond their powers to
contribute but they'll also have power
so whatever they end up doing it'll look
really cool so let me know in the
comments what was your favorite part of
the episode was it hearing the Jay
Garrick name drop from Henry Allen or
wasn't watching Barry getting absorbed
into the Speed Force he's not dead he's
definitely not dead there's just like so
many big pop points that they just set
up so hopefully they'll pay off some of
them before the end of the season we
know that we're gonna learn who the man
in the iron mask is during the final
episode so right now I'm just thinking
based on this episode and the evidence
we've seen in the past he is going to be
earth to Henry Allen why you guys wait
for my next video to post if you haven't
seen it you can click here for my Game
of Thrones video from last night and you
can click here for my Black Panther
Civil War video I'm actually doing a
giveaway as part of that too so thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight